une année entière de travail pour 4
minutes de vol à peine croyable c'est
quand vous voulez monsieur je suis prêt
allons voir si
on a une violation du périmètre
merci
journal de bord de buzz l'éclair
après une année complète coincé sur
cette planète
on est venu d'effectuer notre premier
vol d'essai
[Musique]
rentré ma maison bonne chance cependant
bien reçu
m
oui
bonjour je m'appelle sox et je suis ton
robot de compagnie
nous sommes poursuivis par un mastodonte
[Musique]
absolument terrifiant je regrette
d'avoir accompagné
non
je peux émettre un son propice au
sommeil tu as le choix entre nuit d'été
va de l'océan chant des baleines ont le
bruit blanc sait très bien parfait bonne
nuit sox bonne nuit buzz